baziakova نتيجة المخطط لها
الأجهزة ستكون تماما insham كان
تم اتخاذ قرار بعدم رؤية النيران المجنحة
ساموستينو
نقاط اتصال نائب المدافع بصريًا
مخصص لتظليل القوى العاملة ميسي
ستعطي نقاط حراسة للمحتلين
ينتمون إلى أول قارب في ويدستون
دوستو متريف لقصف التربة السوبروتيف
محاربينا مصابون بالحواجب من هذا النوع
الجناح عبارة عن عربة والمتبادل مختلف
Showan MTR هنا في مناورتها ومناوراته
سوف ترى النار في ساعة من إطلاق النار
تمكن المبعوثون الأوكرانيون الخاصون من ذلك
قريبا ستصل إلى المدينة حتى 15 ملم
كان لا يزال قيد التجميع
اثنين من مخاطر الخدمة الروسية
أعطى السكان الأقوياء مجموعة هنا
مناورة الأنين على ما كان في المرحلة المتداعية
طاقم chikuvaniya BOD يخضع لها
تردد الراديو ولكن طائرة بدون طيار من شأنها أن تساعد
كشف فاني باراميتش لا شيء عدو
غسلها إرسال مواقعهم
اللصوص هنا غير مرتاحين لمناوراتهم
هاون مدفعي مكثف
ما زال قصف حبرنا يحدث في
وضع معسر شبه مقرر
لمبدأ الصورة الرمزية
تم تسليم Effy Bucket إلى الترفيه المطور في
لماذا ليس في العدو